[Music]
well thanks for coming everybody I'm
excited to be here I recently got it
excited about something I was doing that
was I got really excited about PWA s so
I started to look into it and put this
presentation together on web workers
service workers in pwace Who am I I'm a
full-stack developer I'm a freelancer I
was a digital nomad for a while scuba
guide was my office on the Caribbean
that's cool that's my email you can find
the code for this there's not a whole
lot of code for this but there's a
little bit code for this on the github
there and if you're into it so what am i
doing I am a poverty abolitionist
the world used to be flat we used to buy
and sell people we used to make kids
work in factories I believe it's time we
should abolish poverty if you're
interested in that come and talk to me
about it it's really my jam if you guys
are into it
this hacktivism for economic justice get
in touch with me through that I'm
looking to find people who are
interested in helping out projects
around this so but tonight I'm really
excited to be here with you guys PDX
know we're gonna talk about web workers
service workers and PWA eggs so I'm sure
you all know regular web pages they're
just regular it's just your HTML and
your CSS if you do ctrl escape I can't
do it in full screen but you do control
escape you can see all the processes
that are going on in Chrome and what's
interesting is that the web page and
it's really actually really cool about
the JavaScript engine right runs on the
event loop and what that means is the
code is actually pretty easy to think
about but you also get kind of the
simulation of multiple processes and
stuff right you can do basic stuff but
it's you really get limited access to
CPU disk and memory and you end up with
the event loop just being one process
per tab all right are you guys all
familiar with the event loop is that
yeah okay
yeah okay got it so what's the event
loop the event loop is like a while loop
and it's like while there's stuff to do
and then it does stuff and when it gets
to certain places in stuff it'll
actually go back to the top of the
amount live and look for other events so
you wind up with kind of this queue of
all these events happening and then it
processes each event as it comes up to
the top of the queue sometimes in the
processing of an event you'll get to a
place where it can actually put that on
pause and go do another one which is why
you'll actually see in the code later I
wrote myself a bug that took me about an
hour to figure out because I wrote wild
true wild true is not friendly for the
event loop but that's that's really the
gist of it if you're familiar with
computers and you have like multiple
processors and you have multiple CPUs
like this computer has eight processors
or yeah eight processors more or less
available with regular web pages you can
really only have your stuff run on one
processor and so if you're if you want
to do something that like takes if you
want to use all eight processors from
your webpage you can do that now and you
can do that with something called web
workers if if you're if you've ever seen
this like page unresponsive this is
because the event loop got stuck right
and and so that's this is kind of the
symptom of what we're gonna try to solve
so we don't have this problem
so web workers they have two basic
things you can create another process
and then you can pass messages between
the processes so you don't get shared
memory or anything like that I think
there are some rules around local
storage that you get to and get access
data that way too so here's an example
of a script tag on a regular web page
you can see here we're gonna create this
new worker and this worker je s is upon
to show you here the minute what we're
doing here in this piece of code is
we're listening for an event which is a
message event when that message event
happens we're gonna we're going to
append some text to this to this result
we show you guys this example if you can
just imagine there's a an element with
gaddy result we're gonna actually add to
its inner HTML the data from the event
which is which was passed to us as a
message now here in this this bit here
so this is gonna this is going to be
what the web worker sent is us right so
we are now I would pick to call connect
settings you know when we create web
worker it actually goes up loads of this
js5 and now we're gonna listen for these
message events from in this in this
process is happening on the united
states email right now this one what
we're gonna do here is we're gonna set
timeout and we are gonna post a message
to the web worker so we can communicate
to the web worker through messages and
the web worker can communicate to us
with your messages right so this is how
we can get like useful stuff in and out
of the web worker the web worker doesn't
really have any like data or context to
it so we really have to send it through
through messages is that does that make
sense anybody anybody have questions
about that yeah what can you pass it as
a message
maybe object with those yeah but not
like a Dom element uh you can't you
can't you can passing a copy of a
document
you'd be passing a copy of Dom info me
but the web worker doesn't have any
access to the Dom so I can't use like
jQuery good yeah in the web work if you
can load in other scripts so you can
load in low - in other libraries like
that but the data that you have the data
you pass that of course has to be has to
be basically I think I think you could
do a JavaScript object exactly yeah you
can't you can't pass a reference okay so
here's our worker jas are gonna listen
for messages from the main paid for the
string messages so when we get into this
we find itself that's now we're gonna
add this event listener and this is just
like we did on the previous page right
and so now we're gonna say okay worker
got a message this is a horrible
Fibonacci number generator it's made
it's designed to be very poor
performance but it's designed like that
to show the really the value of web
worker right and then here we are going
to so this loop here this is this is
where that Wow a lottery didn't work so
here we set an interval and then every
200 milliseconds we calculate Fibonacci
number
back to the index webpage so right so
this is a lot this is a lot of the
comments that we actually just talked
about questions so yes you can do
multiple processes right like we had
those two scripts and then we had to
event loops running so we could get two
CPUs going we can use this in about 94%
of browsers like I said nope Dom access
and in terms of like practical
applications one of these is the crypto
miner ball where that makes a great web
worker right because you can just spin
up all these CPUs and then another one
my sister pointed this one that's a name
which is PDF jas which is a lie mental
process PDFs on the browser alright so
you guys remember the code we just
looked at so here's here's that code in
action so we're gonna we're gonna go
there and now we're gonna look at this
and sorry it's so small but you can see
that we're running we're getting our
Fibonacci numbers and and now
okay so if you go if you go to that
github you'll see there's a couple out
of these like sidebars so we can do
import scripts so we can also do XML
HTML request so I read the readme and
this is this is text removal here you
can see where the page actually sends
the message and the worker got the
message okay we're in this twice and
then when we got that message we changed
from by pretty things to about five so
that's it so this is an example of our
web worker I think our web worker is
still if you guys can see my CPUs you
know so we have a hundred four on CPU so
we're still we're using like a hundred
percent of a CPU in this page but it's
still responsive and if if we didn't
have the web worker going we'd probably
get that unresponsive page under spent
like Facebook page right so you know so
that's really the value of web workers
do you guys have any questions about
that about what happened here yeah yeah
yeah now this is so I'm a little uh a
little improv and improv here I think we
got it
yeah yeah no it's it's jamming it's like
I'm the worst Fibonacci thing ever
yeah I don't know what I wonder if
that'll happen let me try it let's try
that that sounds fun okay right and so
we did break point because you can see
my CPU went down X is 3 yeah nice
service workers now service workers are
web workers service workers have a cane
I use of about 74% and that's going to
change in the next version of edge
Safari and iOS Safari so it's going to
jump up to be pretty pretty mainstream
[Music]
service workers give you like all that
web worker stuff plus you get a
JavaScript fried proxy to edit responses
of your page network requests so we're
going to talk about that and you get an
installation life cycle so it's almost
like an app and you get push
notifications and other other app like
stuff Google is really excited about
pwace Google is really really excited
about this so how many of all y'all know
what a proxy is and are like we should
skip ok ok so what is a proxy a proxy is
basically an intermediary for requests
from clients seeking resources to other
servers so when my laptop wants to go
out and talk to slides com to get this
presentation it's on the it's on the
Wi-Fi so the first proxy that it hits is
the Wi-Fi right then that Wi-Fi access
point that's going to hit the upstream
router and that's another proxy and so
it's just proxies all the way up
it's like Turtles all the way down
proxies all the way up
and so this so this length this is
almost like this is like something that
never happens right when's the last time
you plug directly into a web server
except on your light on your you're
developing on your own computer right if
you're using the internet you're getting
a proxy in the middle and so we can also
get a caching proxy like you know if
you've ever are you guys familiar with a
caching proxy right so like a like a CDN
like cloud front is a caching proxy
right like I've got my my web site in a
bucket and s3 bucket and if a cloud
front in front of it and then when the
clients want the the data cloud front
only gets it when it knows it's out of
date right so that's a really good
that's a caching proxy okay so if you
wanted to do an offline web app with a
serviceworker you could make something
called a PWA and so then your
serviceworker becomes the proxy right it
has a proxy javascript proxy that edit
response of these two pages network
requests this all happens in the browser
and it has if you have a caching and so
then if you don't have access to the
Internet you can still make that request
based on cash do that's my attempt to
explain that how to do all right cool
all right yes thumbs up I win
serviceworkers also have an installation
lifecycle and so I'm gonna go over this
just briefly to make you aware of it cuz
it's kind of weird it's like
thing for webpages and there's tons of
there's tons of documentation who's
really hot for this basically you can
register your service worker like this I
think so just give the URL instructions
its promise and then the browser will
will download your service worker about
under 24 hours and these scription if
they're updated the way to become
activated so we'll see this but but then
the service worker really just listens
for events and whenever there's a Bechet
minute so network requests will go
through create a ventricle respond all
right this is my guy already I think I
already jabbered on this but yeah it's
really kind of like a native app it's
kind of cool in fact I think I think
chrome and Android are gonna make API
events to put it on your phones like
desktop right so you can get an icon
with it this service workers RS has some
really good examples on it if you want
to see some really cool examples I'll
show this basic one and all right let's
get into this thing all right
okay so so this bit here is the demo
right and it's really just this one
we're a show icon and so really we're
just gonna look at kind of the code
that's going on in this this bit here so
so here's where we here's where we
register our service worker right and
then this bit of code is basically the
UI code for what's going on here now in
the service worker we're gonna so we're
gonna have these named caches and you
can you can update the caches as you go
so these are pre cache URLs so we can
pre cache basically resources that we
need for our application you guys
remember app cache or was it application
cache yeah like I think I think it's
most famous blog post was application
cache ox or something like that
so so this this is kind of like this was
somebody was like alright let's do
something better so we came up with this
so here we can we can basically precache
this index.html and all of our stuff
waiting for the app so then we listen
for the install event and and when
install happens we basically wait and
then we're going to go to our caches and
we're going to open this pre cache cache
and then we're gonna cache a bunch of
stuff and then this skip waiting will
activate any service workers that are
waiting to be activated do you guys
remember that bit all right I hope you
do that's what it does the service
workers if you if you update the Service
Worker it'll wait until it's it's
activated before it starts running all
right so then this bit of code here is
really just cleaning up the old caches
if we if we made a new cache it's not
that awesome but then here's the really
interesting part where we talk about the
proxy right so all of this all this
stuff is just a regular Service Worker
right we were adding listeners and that
all that kind of stuff then we get down
here and we get this fetch of that so
this fetch event is when we get a
network request and I think this is a
Google page so you can see here they're
very concerned about Google Analytics
and so what we're saying is if if the
request starts with are you our location
then we go to our caches and we try to
find a match for the request and then we
just send the response right
so if cache response and response if not
then we open the run time cache right
you remember the run time cache and then
with that cache we run fetch to get the
request and then we add the response we
put the response into the cache and then
we return the response right so I mean
that's pretty that's pretty much the
gist of it and and with this between the
pre cache URLs and this bit here we have
everything we need to make an offline
web app right you can cache all your
images all your resources all your
styling your markup your JavaScript and
then anything you need a runtime you can
do here so when we got to this part here
when we get to this fetch if if fetch
actually returns an error because the
network's down we could just return a
default image right so we could see we
can also start to edit our responses
right like we could change everything
that's in the response right we could
make a pirate speak if we wanted all
right yeah exactly so there's there's a
lot of stuff you can do inside this
proxy it doesn't have to just do this so
it turns out it turns out like PW A's
are hot and people are into it and I I
wouldn't actually I mean I like I got
into it cuz I wanted to learn it for
this talk and also I just want to learn
it but you you really don't need to know
but much about pwh to actually build an
offline
app like this like if you guys are into
UJS here's how to get you know here's
how to get one and it's you just get
your outfits
no it no no it's good it's good I was
super into this yeah I'm just like still
poverty abolitionist and thank you and
that's what Jam what were you gonna say
[Applause]
[Music]